I'd love to see more thoughts because
that's what makes another existence
possible
[Music]
sure free itself from the seduction of
words and thought
and I will let Steve Taylor start and
I'm tough on time Steve so okay I'll
bear that in mind uh good morning
everybody
um I'm on the side of Dostoevsky and
Nietzsche it sounds a bit pretentious
but but um yeah I I I disagree with
descar
um
again that's something I think I thought
I'd never say but I think the kind of
self which is associated with thinking
is a kind of superficial even illusory
type of self I think a real authentic
self or a more authentic self more
essential self emerges when we stop
thinking in moments when our mind is
quiet and empty
but it's important to bear in mind that
I think you know you can broadly speak
and you can differentiate between two
different types of thinking there is
what you could call rational conscious
thoughts uh which which you use to
evaluate things to critically analyze
things we use it to plan to decide to
organize and so forth and that's
obviously a great tool it's a great you
know it's one of the great advantages of
being human that we can use this this
conscious thought
but unfortunately I don't think much of
our thought is actually of that type I
think probably 95 have thought well
maybe I'm talking about my own mind here
this is obviously the one I know best 95
of our thinking it tends to be kind of
random associational involuntary chatter
it's like the stream of Consciousness
you could call it it tends to focus on
the future the past uh Daydreams about
alternate realities and it stops us
being present and it creates a kind of
filter that stands between us and
reality like a fog of abstraction which
stops US really experiencing the world
around us it can stop us really
communicating with one another because
there's so much sort of random chatter
in a mind that we don't really
communicate fully or don't really we're
not really present to other people so it
would be great if we could increase the
amount of rational conscious thought we
have and decrease the amount of chatter
that we have also this chapter tends to
gravitate towards negative things tends
to gravitate towards Warriors problems
resentments it tends to inflate them so
it can cause quite a lot of Discord in
our lives and I think most of the the
really happy moments you know the
happiest moments in our lives arise when
we stop thinking
in Psychology there's a concept called
flow that you've probably heard of which
is when our minds are intensely absorbed
in an activity and the stimulation
activity and I mind's making very quiet
there's a sense of energetic fullness
within us a sense of energy a sense of
well-being and also meditation you know
meditation that the very aim of many
types of meditation is to empty the mind
to stop thinking and when we do that we
feel this marvelous kind of Rich energy
inside of this marvelous fullness of
being
so it would be great if um if thinking
could be a tool that we sort of pick up
when we need it and when we don't need
it we can put it down again and enjoy a
kind of uh a kind of a mental emptiness
mental quietness which would give us a
more authentic and essential sense of
identity
okay thank you very much
in The Killing
sorry I found myself kind of writing a
script
um but it's interesting what you just
said about flow because that's what I'm
going to start with and
I'd I'd like to kind of second a lot of
what you've said
so as an artist I know really well the
feeling of being in flow you know when
that happens or thoughts kind of fall
away and it's
um it's an Indescribable feeling that
it happens especially when I'm creating
something so a story or some writing or
a recording
and I've experienced this feeling of
being in flow not just
when I'm creating something so so in
terms of culture but also when I'm
swimming or you know doing yoga or
listening to music
and on stage I've felt the flow of
energy from an audience and I've thrown
it back at them all before we've had a
moment to even form a thought
and it's a wonderful experience and some
people call this flow God and some
people
call it something else and some people
have no idea what it is right
but when I meditate as you mentioned
meditation I reach a similar place where
I'm resting with the contents of my mind
and I notice my thoughts but importantly
I'm not pulled Along by them
um I can sense the space kind of
underneath my thoughts The Emptiness and
I can rest there and it can feel
blissful
so there is an enormous amount of
benefit in being without thought
especially while creating art which is
culture
however
there is still a place for thought I
used to work in improvised theater I was
in a company of four actors and we used
to have to go all night every on stage
every night and improvise two plays with
an interval in between an hour long each
and before each show the audience would
vote on who we were and where we were so
they might say your three bridesmaids
and a bride in a kitchen and then the
director would come back and tell us and
we'd look through our costumes and put
something relevant on and come out and
improvise this play
so the reason I tell you about this is
that improvised theater isn't
an extreme form of of present culture
what happens every night is brand new
it's happening right now and it can
never be repeated
but there were rules and some of you
might be familiar with the rules of
improvisation you know accept what's
offered that kind of thing and those
rules have been considered and devised
over a long time and they work
my background before acting was in
Circus and magic and escapology and they
all require you know dexterity and quick
quick thinking quick reactions and they
also require hours of practice and
thought
the magician Tommy Cooper I don't know
if you know Tommy Cooper but he's he had
this signature kind of Comedy magic act
and he put huge amounts of thought into
producing what looked like a chaotic
off-the-cuff character
so there is a freedom away from the
seduction of thought
and when you dip your paintbrush into
paint and you Splash it against the
canvas
you know that's that's a relinquishing
of control and artistically it's really
valuable
but thought enables us to communicate
and to create collectively and to learn
from our mistakes and successes and to
plan our next piece of work
thought is often what enables those
producing culture to enjoy the
thoughtlessness of being in flow
thank you and Andy what do you have
um
so should culture avoid the seduction of
words and thought
um I I think we should make words and
thought more seductive than they are at
the moment
um there's a there's an experience I had
earlier this year in February which has
really stuck with me I was in a woman's
prison uh where I'd been teaching for a
while and I had a relatively new class
and
um
I was filling up my whiteboard with the
uh
theory of moral consequentialism this
idea that an action is good or bad
depending on the outcomes that it has
rather than depending on a
a religious framework or whether whether
because of some system of reason and
ideas I was explaining the story of
consequentialism
and and one of the women in the class
just had this huge grin on her face
and I was kind of I was kind of aware of
it I was a bit distracted by it but I
was kind of carried on anyway and
Earnest kind of explaining this Theory
and um
and then she just started laughing
and I said what's up and it was Arie
um and I I said what's up and she said
so people actually sit down
and write out all this kind of stuff
about what makes something good or bad
and I'm like yeah that's that's kind of
what philosophers do that's that's the
study of philosophy that's the practice
of philosophy
and she just laughed again and said but
so you're telling me they actually do
that like as a thing
and she said isn't it just like
childhood though that kind of makes you
who you are and like where you're born
and then that's kind of just how you
turn out to be
and I found it
I found it really moving actually uh
that kind of um
almost like naked uh confession of like
fatalism and determinism and obviously
that had been
um perhaps part of her life the fact
that she'd ended up in prison
um it also kind of made sense uh given
the kind of uh layer of society she was
in uh prisons are not a world that are
touched by Good Sense most of the time I
think we all know uh most of society
know most politicians no most policy
makers know what would make that world
better what would improve it they know
which ideas work they know which ideas
don't work but the actual public will or
political courage to actually make those
improvements just don't happen
so it's not a surprise that in that
setting Big Ideas becomes quite
literally laughable
um
but you know uh I sort of carried on in
Earnest with Ari and we had a great uh
three months together and uh I think she
really enjoyed the class
um I I suppose my feeling with the
student like that is it doesn't it
doesn't have to be this way
uh and you know there is there is a
history uh in the working class of like
um
of education and ideas and thought and
intellectual enrichment uh what got
called the the mutual Improvement
societies that you'd have where uh Mill
workers or factory workers uh would uh
gather together and pull resources to
build libraries and uh teach each other
bits they learned from politics
literature art ethics
um you know uh what's what was called
bettering yourself
I think those movements were the things
that that gave rise to the labor
movement that they were part of a sort
of organized working class they didn't
come out of philanthropy that that those
libraries weren't uh given from above uh
um they weren't state-funded
um and and so uh what I want is more of
that that those kind of movements
couldn't really exist today in the age
of the zero hours contract and in the
age of the Uber driver and in the age
where
certain companies make it illegal for
you to join unions but
I suppose when I think of this question
of culture should culture avoid the
seduction of thought
you know we talk what do we mean by
culture are we talking Capital C culture
or are we talking
Society in general and and I think in
society in general
I'd love to see more thoughts because
because
that's what makes another existence
possible that's what makes if if you can
think if you can imagine another
possible existence for yourself then
that's that's what can free you one of
the things that can free you from the
kind of fatalism that Ari had
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas